With our packed level actors now wrapped up, that is going to bring us to the end of our
introduction to optimization tutorial. To quickly recap, we started this by talking about
optimization philosophy. Remember, you should optimize at every stage of your project. It
shouldn't be an optimization part. Optimization is something that is everybody's responsibility
and will work from the lifetime of your project. We then took a look at some of the
ways we can optimize our project right at the setup, including changing the rendering mode
between the deferred renderer and the forward renderer. We then took a look at some texture
optimizations, including mipmapping and ensuring that our textures are a power of
two so that they work with the streaming system. We then looked at ways to optimize
our static and skeletal meshes, including Nanite. Also ways that we could use Unreal's built-in
level of detail tools should Nanite not be supported on the platform that we're using.
We then took a look at material optimizations and how we can utilize material instances to
help speed up our workflow, and also covered some things that we don't want to do to ensure
that we have the optimal material setup inside of our project. We then took a look at some of
the optimization view modes Unreal Engine 5 provides to help us visually see where our performance
issues might be hurting our level once we've identified that a certain feature is causing
performance issues. Remember with the optimization view modes, you don't necessarily want to just
look at them and then blindly optimize. You want to get some performance data from the performance
capture tools and then use the optimization view modes to help verify that data and then make
optimizations accordingly. Last but not least, we went over some of the optimization tools that
Unreal Engine 5 provides to help you better optimize your project. These included things like
the reference viewer or the size map viewer and many more tools that, again, allow you to
understand where you are spending the precious resources inside of any Unreal Engine 5 project.
Well, that is all that I have for you today. I want to thank you for watching. Again, my name
is Sam Deiter. I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with Epic Games and I will see you next time.